I want to start work on a new piece a  piece about rebirths the inevitable pull  that they exert and our efforts to  escape them now but Suzi you will  improvise freely at its heart I'm  interested in your instincts here  the piece will be called Vida Earthman  open again Ali  [Music]  you  [Music]  at the beginning she gave me things  perfect balance perfect sleep she wants  to get inside of me I can feel her she  can see me  [Music]  when you dance the dance of another you  make yourself in the image of its  creator I feel like I'm not even here  yet complex incredible the way she  transmitted some work you have to decide  what is it you want to be for this  company there's more in that building  than what you can see dr. living there's  dangerous people three mothers play God  the tavern mother tenant album Maserati  marvel  mother Billy all darkness inside and we  do some kind of deal with them  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  the one that's coming  [Music]  you